[SPEAKER_00]: Unknown date to be decided later.
[SPEAKER_00]: When your character is 23, when Paul is 23, his mother dies.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is you at her deathbed with Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: With what?
[SPEAKER_00]: With Prince Jeon II.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, your mother is dying.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Prince John is standing there as you grab her right hand and he is holding her left hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And she kind of, she is coming in and out of consciousness at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mother has
[SPEAKER_00]: Always, since you remember, had way too much to drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that, with the grief that she's been dealing with, has aged her considerably, especially in these last few years.
[SPEAKER_00]: John is a man that's probably about 45 years old now.
[SPEAKER_00]: 48 years old now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, how old's my mom?
[SPEAKER_00]: About that age.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four and a five.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the way she has basically lived, she's at least 20 years older and not in good health.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: So... What's killing her is the sickness.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's something that would normally kill a healthy person.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's some kind of a flu.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, because of her weakened state and the way she is and her grief, she has basically not been able to deal with this sickness.
[SPEAKER_00]: She has a moment of clarity and she looks at you and says, Paul, what will you do without me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Please.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't believe you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Am I supposed to respond to that?
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have to if you don't want to.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be okay, Mom.
[SPEAKER_01]: You say, I'll be okay, Mom?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: She looks over at Jeon and goes, You will take care of him, won't you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jeon, please, this is my brother.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is your duty.
[SPEAKER_00]: The prince looks at you and says, Of course he will be taken care of.
[SPEAKER_00]: He is my blood, as are you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will do right by him.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you tell me who his father is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so she kind of looks back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right here, right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: She looks back, she looks at John and says, I know you've hated me for years, John.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you, I know you, not, she doesn't say, I know you've hated me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've known, I know you've wanted to know this history for years, John.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, know that your father was a good man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I loved him greatly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: I promised I would never reveal who he was.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was to come back to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was to come back.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then she looks at Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's of royal blood, brother.
[SPEAKER_00]: I loved him dearly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do not hold my secret against me on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I fear that if you, I fear that if it was known what had happened, the scandal that has been my life would be greater.
[SPEAKER_00]: John kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then he says, she says, promise me, promise me that you will do right by your nephew.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then she dies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your uncle begins to cry.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can tell that he cared for her greatly.
[SPEAKER_00]: You always knew this, but you realize right then because the guy is a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince of Pirates and has seen a lot of horrible shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's seen a lot of people die.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this one obviously hit home.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this was a big blow to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he puts your sister's hands on her body and he takes her hand away from you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gently!
[SPEAKER_00]: Not in a mean way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And puts it there and then closes her eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then he says to you, Well, Paul, at least her suffering is over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Know that I know it is not your fault that she never...
[SPEAKER_00]: Would tell me the truth of things about your father.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume you have as much resentment towards her as I do regarding that fact.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will honor her wishes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will not throw you into the world.
[SPEAKER_00]: That'd be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a good start.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, to be honest with you, I have
[SPEAKER_00]: No real use for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: This wing of the castle...
[SPEAKER_00]: I allowed your sister, I mean your mother to have it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hopefully it would give her some solace.
[SPEAKER_00]: However...
[SPEAKER_00]: I do have other relatives.
[SPEAKER_00]: You and I do have other relatives.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whose station is above yours.
[SPEAKER_00]: And who could move in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would ask that you move back into your mother's childhood apartments.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're on the east side of the castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: You lived there as a child.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I like it?
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't hate it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, it's very isolated.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you've been there a few times.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's small.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it has a really nice view overlooking the ocean.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact,
[SPEAKER_00]: In a way, you felt very uncomfortable in the opulence that your mother demanded.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can imagine.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think your uncle is making a, not a horribly unreasonable thing, a request at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not really a request, it's gonna happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's telling you it's gonna happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he spent a lot of money on you and your sister, I mean you and your mother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And kept her living in a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Lifestyle that was equivalent to what Jeon lived.
[SPEAKER_01]: As long as I'm not being moved to a shithole.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to be put in the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not going to stick you in the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's going to stick you in the corner.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's not a bad corner.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I like it, then I'll be okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's definitely a downgrade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's like, you know, moving from the honeymoon suite down to a normal room.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Single bedroom.
[SPEAKER_00]: And a good hotel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then Jeon says, moreover,
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, we can talk of this later, but in the coming months, I plan to more and more exclude you from the Monmurgian Council.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you've been there in the past, as my sister has demanded, but in truth,
[SPEAKER_00]: I see no reason for you to have to attend.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can pursue your own interests, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: The library will always remain open to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just avoid the peak uses.
[SPEAKER_00]: What does my character think of this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think I'm surprised.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not surprised.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're disappointed.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's very apparent to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, so the thing is, is you can try and ask your uncle for more stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the thing is, is obviously he is, he's saying something.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've never really understood why your uncle said no to you, except the fact that you knew your mother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uncle, you've never really given me a chance.
[SPEAKER_00]: You say that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What use are you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why don't we find out?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've been teaching myself for the last 23 years.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you believe you have some value?
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there is that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have to make a persuasion roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look at your persuasion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I even have persuasion as a skill?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it's, well, I mean, it's a minus two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a DC, I'm gonna call it a DC 10 persuasion roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a challenge role.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like you're trying to make a decision against the guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a DC 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have to roll a 12 or higher.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if you roll really good, he might actually be convinced to do something better.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, if you want to, you can make an argument for yourself, and I'll give you a bonus if you make a really good one.
[SPEAKER_01]: I slip around the castle and nobody ever notices that I'm here or gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: I show up when I want and nobody notices me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why can't we use that?
[SPEAKER_01]: What use would that be?
[SPEAKER_01]: I could get knowledge from other people not knowing I'm there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm a ghost in these halls.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have heard tale that you are very slippery.
[SPEAKER_00]: What use would this be, though?
[SPEAKER_01]: Say someone put a hit on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I bet you I'd find out before you would.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do have many security guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: That may be true, but are they as great as intelligence of mine?
[SPEAKER_00]: Intelligence is not everything, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Intelligence is not everything, but I can see things before they come.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can see things before they come?
[SPEAKER_01]: If someone starts talking of something that's gonna happen, I'm gonna be there to notice it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I will know of action to take before it happens.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll your persuasion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did it work?
[SPEAKER_01]: The argument?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did I?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll tell you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, well done.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I lost you when you started to tell me about your second interview.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is intriguing.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do believe you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I do believe your intentions.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think what is also important is that I do believe your loyalty to the family.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, you wish to be useful.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, the duties that you are suggesting for yourself
[SPEAKER_00]: Are usually done by a spy master.
[SPEAKER_00]: A very experienced one.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I have several.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is dangerous work.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something that I do not think my sister, your mother, would like you to be involved in.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I will take this into consideration.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, um... Let me think upon it.
[SPEAKER_00]: If this is of interest to you...
[SPEAKER_00]: If this is of interest to you, I see no reason why you cannot be trimmed in this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know of Lord Jamis, do you not?
[SPEAKER_00]: I will speak to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you know, Lord Jamis is my spymaster.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not promising you anything, but if anyone will be able to give you tutelage in this area, it would be him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that sufficient?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, um, yeah, just keep in touch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, I'm heartbroken at this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Talk to you later.
Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will talk with you later.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you wish.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do not need to remove your stuff from the swing now, but by the end of the week I wish you to have moved into your new accommodations.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I go through my mother's possessions?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to be there when I go through my mother's possessions?
[SPEAKER_00]: I am going to go through your mother's possessions and I will give you everything that I think belong to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now roll an insight roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, insight is wisdom, which is plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: 12, 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know what he's doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's trying to figure out who your father is.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's not slighting you necessarily, but he wants to figure out things about your mother that she did not tell him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he wants to have, it's probably not him that's going to be going through the mother's possessions.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's going to be somebody else.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's going to be Billy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to know who my father was too.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see that, Jonas?
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you and he goes...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a mystery we both want to find and perhaps, Paul, this is what will join us.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's anything you remember or anything you know about your father, please let me know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will let you know what I find.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we go through my mother's possessions together then?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the reason why is that there are some things better left unknown.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have suspicions of things, and if they are true,
[SPEAKER_00]: I will have you learn of them gently.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do have your best intentions at heart.
[SPEAKER_00]: Understand that nephew.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you trust me on this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I will.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You trust me, I will trust you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: So.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jeon is as good as his word.
[SPEAKER_00]: He allows you to move into your mother's childhood chambers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is...
[SPEAKER_00]: A small little room.
[SPEAKER_00]: Size of this room, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably, but actually it's very similar to the size of this room.
[SPEAKER_00]: About the size of this room and with a veranda, a deck, that overlooks the cliffs to the royal docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe a hundred feet below.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's very, actually very nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's an offshoot this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is the bedchamber, which is probably about, I would say, 15 feet wide.
[SPEAKER_00]: A very nice bed in there, a table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then there's a closet.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I've drawn it for you here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Each one of those things is five feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: So is this the door?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the closet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Closet.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the veranda, and in fact,
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the balcony outside.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are things that are drawn here.
[SPEAKER_00]: No bathroom?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, that's down the hall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if that'll work out for me, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it's a pretty private wing and there are chamber pots and usually you go to the bathroom in the chamber pots.
[SPEAKER_00]: And go down to the common bathroom area and pour them out.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's pretty much how everybody does it in a castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: So by the end of the week, you've moved your stuff into that room.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you've gotten things pretty well set up.
[SPEAKER_00]: The accommodations are good.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're feeling
[SPEAKER_00]: Disconcerted by the loss of your mother, but you're also feeling like things could have been a lot worse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the way that that was pretty much the first time you ever talked to your uncle in a way that was sort of genuine and sort of also without your mother's counseling and you're actually very interested in the way he responded because even though it was sort of like wait and we'll see
[SPEAKER_00]: It wasn't a no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which, beforehand, he always gave you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you have been totally used to hearing no from that guy a lot of times.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, there is news of trouble with the Kingdom of Keoland this week.
[SPEAKER_00]: And apparently there was some kind of conflict happening where the Kiwish fleet is stopping trade merchants from coming to the city of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, this is very strange because usually
[SPEAKER_00]: The Key West Navy would not have a chance or even try such a thing because the Monmurgian Navy would be out there making sure that the trade lanes were open.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a conflict that Keoland normally cannot deal with.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you feel a strange sense of urgency this month and in a way you kind of become forgotten because there's so many discussions going on with
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince Jeon, other Commodores, and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't really blame him for, I would say, ignoring you, but... Well, I've already been... You've already been ignored, but he's made a promise to you that he would look into things for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, by the end of the week after you've moved out, a couple of days have gone by and still he has not summoned you or talked to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, once again, you've been forgotten in this place.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You also notice that the guards of the city are on higher alert.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you catch rumors from some of the servants that there actually have been some riots in Lower City and Market Square.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is weird, because normally at the beginning of
[SPEAKER_00]: The end of winter, which is kind of where you're at right now, the trade ships start rolling in from around the world to begin trading and selling wares in the great market.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's tension.
[SPEAKER_00]: And for there to be tension in the royal palace, which is usually very much pampered, it's bizarre.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, you get into a routine, waiting for your uncle to talk to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the days roll by, I'd say a week rolls by before your, I mean since your mother had died, and you find yourself
[SPEAKER_00]: In your room, isolated as usual, sitting there reading a book when you decide to light an opium stick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Present in this scene...
[SPEAKER_00]: The climate in Monmurg is that of, I would say, the Caribbean.
[SPEAKER_01]: I read the thing about what the kind of temperature is here usually.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, so think of this as like a Florida or Louisiana type place, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: That kind of stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: And normally what you do is you light an opium stick and you close the
[SPEAKER_00]: Subtitles by the Amara.org community